[Music]
care to take a tour inside your
own body no i don't suggest
you do capsule endoscopy you know the
one that takes pictures
inside your digestive tract or an x-ray
let's take the most sophisticated
hypothetical tour
where you would be your own guide what i
have in mind might seem
a bit out there but picture this
what if all of your organs were mini use
running their own departments and
dealing with each other's characters
how would they cooperate this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you can look
inside your body
your body is a complex machine made up
of nearly 100 trillion cells
they're constantly replicating dying and
being replaced with new ones you have
five
vital organs that you can't live without
and a few organs
that you don't really need and now you
get a chance to meet them all
[Music]
this is the head of the circulatory
department and the hardest working of
all of your organs your heart is a
muscular organ that pumps blood
throughout your body all day and
all night it delivers oxygen and
nutrient-rich blood
to all parts of your body via arteries
and receives oxygen and
nutrient poor blood back via veins
your heart slows down when you sleep but
when it gets signals of danger
it starts pumping blood faster to
deliver more oxygen to your cells and
tissues
but it doesn't work alone it receives
deliveries of oxygen from your lungs the
head of the respiratory department
oxygen in carbon dioxide out move it out
i don't need any of this waste in the
system
do you hear this that is your digestive
system two floors down
and it's breaking down your lunch but
before we get there
you've got to meet someone upstairs
your mouth is like an intern working for
a few departments
simultaneously it can cover for your
nose and take in oxygen for the
respiratory department
and it also begins the process of
digestion for the digestive department
then the food travels down your
esophagus all the way to the stomach
[Music]
your stomach produces gastric juice that
breaks down proteins and
kills off potentially dangerous bacteria
what used to look like a yummy slice of
pizza turns into this
[Music]
paste and is released into your small
intestine
this six meter long organ absorbs all
the nutrients from your lunch
and sends them through your bloodstream
and into the liver
[Music]
your liver true neat freak it breaks
down drugs
detoxifies all the harmful chemicals and
sends them out of your body as ways
and it hates when you get drunk
and these are the kidneys just like the
liver these guys are a couple of little
neat freaks
they clean the waste and excess fluid
from your blood
and send all that stuff out of your body
as urine
[Music]
all these processes are controlled from
the command center
your brain it has about 100 billion
employees the nerve cells and with their
help
the brain sends and receives messages
from all the other departments of your
body
yeah your brain's got some control
issues everything has to be as it says
then you've got some workers that aren't
that essential
take the spleen hiding in the back of
the ribs and on the left side of the
abdomen
it essentially has the same function as
the liver
[Music]
and here's another one the appendix it
sits at the junction of the large and
small bowels
waiting to catch an inflammation from
the intestine
that's when you get appendicitis and
need to remove this sneaky
organ from your body
but most of the workers inside your body
are essential
they all come with their own set of
responsibilities and
if they fail it's not good for the
entire system
the defense department your immune
system looks into
all the cells that enter your system
it's always ready to attack bacteria
viruses and parasites
but sometimes that's not enough and your
body needs
external health in the form of
medication
[Music]
jokes aside if you could take a look
inside your body
and anytime you wanted you'd be able to
detect
if anything is wrong with it and live
longer
and if increasing your life longevity is
something you're interested in well
we've got another show for you to help
you survive
whatever awaits you
[Music]